California's wine country is trying to
rebuild after the deadly wildfires
nearly three months ago the flames
damaged some 30 wineries in Napa Sonoma
and Mendocino counties but long before
the disaster a different horror rocked
the famous region an unlikely
confrontation between an entrepreneur in
the Silicon Valley investor led to
violence and bloodshed Tracy Smith
investigates for tomorrow night's 48
hours here's a preview
he calls 9-1-1 and he's yelling at the
phone help me help me he shot me this is
the actual transcript yeah and the 9-1-1
call yes
so he's running through the vineyard he
was running through the vineyard and the
shooter is in the truck coming after him
shooting it window this is crazy crazy
who are these guys
these guys were a couple of rich
ambitious wine lovers who wanted to be
in the business and own their own
vineyards look I have pictures
here's Ahmad Ahmad tough Phyllis he's a
smart guy from Silicon Valley who loved
Hollywood
he even financed a movie and here's the
other guy Robert Dahl an operator who
people said could make money grow on
trees in this case vines was he a good
salesman
great salesman great so anyone Robert
Dahl came from Minnesota where he ran a
decidedly unglamorous mold removal
business he really did have the vision
of having some form of a winery he moved
with his wife and three kids and he hit
the ground running he started with a
wine bottle in company then part
ownership of a vineyard with this man
and then a brewery with Greg and
Francine committal when dole wanted the
ultimate Napa prize his own vineyard he
turned to that Silicon Valley investor
Ahmad Tov Phyllis the money man with
ties to Hollywood take one aimer Tov
Phyllis put in more than a million
dollars a bag of it in cash soon there
was Dahle vineyards
welcome to Dahl vineyards in lovely
young California but it wasn't long
before things turned sour no one that
ever put money into something that he
was doing was ever gonna get anything
back Dahl was making wine money was
vanishing it turned out Dahl had been
conning everyone all along his
contractor his winemaker his co-owner at
the vineyard and his partners at the
brewery but when he conned that
millionaire Hollywood investor Ahmad Tov
Phyllis the whole game came
crashing down who lives who dies it's an
incredible tale of wine money and murder
Tracy Smith is with us from Los Angeles
Tracy that's an incredible preview so
why did this end in murder great
question
money as one Napa local told me money is
intoxicating and when you mix money and
wine you get intoxicated to the second
or third power Tracy how was Dahl able
to con all of his business partners for
so long you know Dahl could talk a good
game he had all the trappings of success
nice house nice car nice motorcycle and
people wanted to believe him they wanted
to believe that he could make their
dreams come true
what so what happened in the shootout
who was chasing whom ha ha I'm not gonna
give you too many details you can watch
on Saturday night just imagine there's
this flashy entrepreneur and this quiet
businessman who has a bag full of
$800,000 in cash that he brought to Napa
and it ends up with a shootout in a
vineyard and murder Wow Tracy thank you
so much for joining us this morning and
you can watch Tracy's full report Grapes
of Wrath that's tomorrow night on 48
hours that's at 10:00 9:00 central right
here on CBS